I am sitting here today because of my
parents and because of my family. We
really are a story about the importance
of education and what education can do. I
mean, consider for a moment the fact that
my great-grandmother was born into
slavery and emancipated at age six and
the fact that my grandparents were
sharecroppers. How do you go from that to
being able to attend some of the best
institutions in the world and now sit in
this wonderful opportunity?
Well, my parents left the rural
segregated south looking for opportunity.
My father went into the Air Force and
when he came out it was the GI Bill and
an opportunity through a management training
program that enabled him to go to
college and my mother as well, she went
to college a little bit later in life
She moved out of the south and worked as
a secretary for several years before she
was able to go to a historically black
college that trained her to be a public
school teacher. As my parents careers
progressed I was able to see what they
were able to do with their lives and it
was the greatest example for me and so
in my life I've seen the importance of
education and how it can take you out of
poverty, but more importantly how it can
give you the agency to have control over
your own destiny.
I was drawn to research on education
because of issues of inequality and
access, but I quickly realized, you know,
education does not end at grade 12.
Students cannot go on and have a
middle-class standard of living if they
end with just a high school degree and
so I've done work trying to help
students get the information they need
and to simplify the processes so that
we're not wasting so much great
potential of students who are doing the
work that they need to do but are
getting lost in a system that was not
designed for their needs.
One thing that
I love about the students at Harvard
Graduate School of Education is each
year the enthusiasm, the hope, and already
the experiences that they bring; I love
the fact that we know that there are
problems in education but we're not
satisfied to just let them continue, and
the students come because they are
prepared to create new things to help in
all sorts of ways and that enthusiasm as
a faculty member is something that I've
always drawn upon and I think the entire
community draws upon.
The Harvard Graduate School of Education is already
in a place of strength. We have done so
much but our work absolutely is not done
When you look and see the continuing
inequities and the opportunities that
are not available, the fact that we waste
so much of student's potential because
they don't have access to high-quality
education, you realize there's so much
more to be done. We are now 50 years
after the war on poverty, we are 50 years
after Martin Luther King's assassination
and we look around and we wonder why
haven't we made more progress, what more
could we do? And then just two weeks ago
the Nation at Risk report that came out
35 years ago, we've realized those
inequities are still very present. It's all while the Harvard
Graduate School of Education has made many
contributions, innovations, impacts on the
field with research, with leaders who are
going out to the world with a strong
purpose and strong skills, we have to
think about ways that we can do more to
spread the knowledge that we have, to
engage with the field, to be a place
where practitioners and leaders and
policymakers can come to learn more and
to engage with each other.